[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans direct
aux lauriers je suis les eaux
je suis fier le concept de caractériel
est plutôt simple fait pour faire court
galloway est 4e avec zéro lula
franchement je sais qu'on va accueillir
aujourd'hui
et bah je te le donne en mille mais je
crois qu'on va accueillir au rial et
youtube l'odm effectivement viala
youtube meuse
aujourd'hui le défi sera simple c'est de
piéger la clientèle bas d'un magasin de
presse mais tu as déjà travaillé dans
une boutique et cosmétiques actuellement
j'ai déjà été vendeuse voilà à l'aise
avec ça et moi s'il te plait merci
beaucoup
la première clients que tu abordé tu as
charbon jour conseillé de mettre de
l'eau sur son visage ne m'attend si vous
voulez avoir bannis par de l'eau le
matin c'est ce que j'ai fait un peu
parce que moi je suis en gueule
de bois moi c'est ce que j'ai fait
je vais deux enfants vous avez des
enfants
oui combien gérant de sa rage et orange
et çà et là comme je te remets ça paie
je suis très seul
je suis très soeur je vous propose des
massages de main aux gens c'est pourtant
massage gratuit
voilà que tu l'ès tunis une caméra
cachée
je ne me reconnaissais pas vous me
reconnaissez pas j'ai été figurante sont
les trois frères j'ai été figurante dans
le film les trois frères de me le cil
pelé pas la bise
je peux vous faire la piste faisant dix
morts à sa fille de partir il vous gêne
c'est la nouvelle maman avec ma nouvelle
et il vous partez pas leur sac et 105
est ce le cachemire moment lui qui avait
fait le tri de ses poubelles et vous pas
que metric beaucoup de déchet mais
asseyez-vous à côté de moi je reviens à
ma demande du samu les manèges et si
elle y est oui tu le ton son siège vous
aimez les manèges
[Applaudissements]
pour rien
[Musique]
voulais pas me faire tourner revient en
est un triste édictées fait frémir et
vais pas pleurer je vous proposions un
massage des joues un peu tu comme
c'était demain sur ses joues et tu ne
bouge pas pendant 5 minutes et ne
parlait pas il faut il se trouvait sans
décoller j'ai envie de vomir
je crois que je suis je et vous savez
quand j'ai envie de vomir je fais des
squats continue et chante en même temps
je fais de toi
naissances et le massage ou fait du bien
ça vous fait du bien aux massages à ce
qu'un semblant de minutes public aurait
en réalité tu bosses pas dans le magasin
c'est pour rigoler bas je fais ça et du
coup vous n'avez pas qu'à son acheteur
du tout c'est dommage ce temps une
boutique on voit des choses j'aime bien
que les chiffres comme ça pour vous
refaire la bise du coup tu en fais 20
c'est bon
[Musique]
allez on sortait 10h10
j'espère que tu es apprécié cette vidéo
en tout cas n'en est encore qu'au type
renouvelle de fort bon je suis pas pour
animer un peu enfin je pense pas que ce
bon bah merci d'avoir regardé vous
pouvez nous retrouver ici n'hésite pas à
s'abonner à la chaîne de vélo moustache
et si tu veux retrouver le premier
épisode de gags dans l'oreillette c'est
juste ici